thanks for being here I'm gonna give you
a second to to hook in and get your but
I'm gonna tell you a little bit about
Pearl what I know about Pearl first of
all I don't know what she was doing
before this but if you've watched her
channel it's bomb it's a I watch I'm
like mesmerized sometimes I can't I
can't stop it it's like an addiction
it's like the old reality TV but like
real reality you know they've warped it
now it's like there's no reality you
know you need a reality TV fix you just
watch Pearl
she's young
she's got a young perspective on things
you know me I'm a little bit of a relic
but it is what it is her Channel's now
at over 900 000 and she had Andrew Tate
on what is last week couple weeks ago
you had him on the panel
um I think it was the 19th of December
when we filmed we released it on
Christmas so I want to ask you about
first of all if you would share you saw
that he got arrested and all that what
was your take when you saw that news
coming in oh my gosh my thought was that
he said he was going to get arrested
I was like he said this was gonna happen
The Matrix I mean I mean I kind of feel
it I was just listening to you I'm like
I don't know the facts of the case you
know it's possible there are facts I
don't know but just my gut is like nah
he said this was gonna happen The Matrix
is after him now he's after him he was
on the show and I'm curious when people
you know I originally had a reaction to
him when I first came into the space I
had watched a bunch of like shorts and
then you get to know him in the long
form content I've not met him in person
though you've now met him in person
you've had him on the show what is it
like before and after the taping like is
the Andrew Tate you see on camera is
that the entertain that you interact
with off camera tell me a little bit
about that okay so I want to add one
thing I was also triggered the first
time I saw him yes I do I saw he had a
cheating party that was the first video
I saw I was like why are you having a
cheating party right and she
said right I was triggered I was
triggered I was like because they were
talking about how rich guys live like
that and my dad's Rich I'm like my dad
does not have cheating parties I was
triggered I was triggered which is good
like and I said I even on the show like
I acknowledge as you know sometimes an
emotional reaction happens I had the
same not to that but to some other toe
self-defense and I had to do a takedown
of myself the other day and humiliate
myself for the audience because it had
to be done but I'm glad you said it oh
maybe I should take down myself that's
it people's videos are so old that
people don't really look at them anymore
but it's cool to see you be like it's
deeply humiliating but it serves a
purpose you know for yourself even to
put your keep yourself in check so what
does he like and what was he like for
the interview I thought it was a
fantastic panel by the way
what was your experience yeah so um it
was really quick in and out because he
had to be gone by I think like nine
um am I at like where I live is kind of
tricky to find sometimes so it was
really quick like it was like he got
there and we're like all right come on
get out like get on the set yeah um but
he was really polite he was really nice
um yeah he was I would say he was
exactly like he was on camera eating the
Clementine yeah the whole interview just
like totally chill well people ask for
behind the scenes and I'm like there
really wasn't much behind the scenes
because it was literally like like he
kind of like I had to help him find the
place yeah and then it was like once he
found it I was just like get on the set
yeah we're rolling and then he had to be
out by a certain time and I was I was
gonna use every minute of air time so I
was like he had to be gone by 9 30. I
entered the show 9 25. it's like I've
used it every minute of this you're like
9 29 30 is when we cut yeah you got five
minutes we got the picture for the
thumbnail I love it so talk to me about
your show like first of all what I love
about it is it feels very authentic to
me like how do you get do you recruit
women who see the world differently from
you've got one older woman on there
that's hilarious yes
but how does it come to be and and what
were you doing before this
um okay so what was I doing before this
I worked in sales for two years I sold
copiers it was horrible and so yeah so I
graduated college I was 21 or 22. then I
moved to Milwaukee I did sales for two
years and I had one Tick Tock go viral
and I was like you know what
I don't really like working and I just
can't and so
um then I went um I moved home with my
parents and I was just like I'm gonna
try out the YouTube thing and um and
then I was supposed to go um to England
anyway I was supposed to because I quit
in like I don't know the fall September
I was supposed to go to England in
December for volleyball and play
volleyball there for a year okay um so
my plan was I'll just like you know try
some set like stuff on the side go to
England and then I'll just play pro
volleyball or whatever
um so that's what I was doing do you
like actively try to get women on the
panel that see the world differently
from you yes okay how do you do that I
it's really hard it's actually
incredibly hard I would say recruiting
is the hardest part of like running the
show because one it's so frequent how
much time you need guests and two like
sometimes if someone does disagree and
you want them back on to disagree like
they see the comments they're not too
high you know you're like
like I had one girl say her body count
on live it was so high I'm like girl
like I don't know what you've been doing
in these streets and and and then
um yeah then she got so mad um but the
way we do it now is we have a recruiter
and he'll pull people off the streets or
through Instagram so he goes in person
and just recruits at like clubs and
um or in the daytime just depends train
stations what and what is your goal like
with it what is your hope is it to
entertain is it to like are you trying
to like reach women out there who are
young women and say like wake up what is
your what do you really want to do with
your show well
I'm trying to answer this in the most
concise way because I sometimes have a
lot of thoughts yeah that's cool you
just spew them all so the first thing I
try not to give advice I feel like it's
kind of hard to give advice when you're
not married right so it's like what I'm
gonna say how to get married when I'm
not married like what how am I going to
help you uh second thing
I am really passionate about
entertainment like I would definitely
not be honest if I said that's not
entertainment is nothing to do with it
yeah I think sometimes on screen you can
have a conversation that represents
society and it's kind of so in a way
when I have Brittany run around I felt
like while Brittany Renner is the girl
in the Forefront there's a million girls
just like her that are coming to the
same realizations that she's having and
so sometimes like you can create a piece
of content that like shows what's hap
happening in society
[Music]
um third thing third thing is I just
think there's a lot of women that have
been brainwashed by feminism and I did
like the one thing that blew up my
channel was me red pilling women and it
was interesting because my friend Jess
who's my roommate it was like that's how
we kind of started I was showing her
Jordan Peterson about the pay Gap I was
showing her Thomas Sowell where they
talk about like how history is
misrepresented in some things and it was
just so interesting for the audience to
see her like you know because she was
someone not that opinionated in the
middle and just change her mind and I
would say of the girls have done the
reaction videos with like I would say 75
become more moderate over time or change
their mind completely interesting yeah
so are you political by Nature because I
mean there are people in this space who
have Traditional Values when it comes to
gender roles but they're not necessarily
politically aligned and then there's
others that fall in line with
conservatism like I do yeah I would say
I'm more conservative okay yeah and are
you into politics is that like your is
that something that because I don't hear
you talk about it really on the show
it's more about a stating relationship I
have my opinions you know I I like the
show to be more about relationships yeah
because I one think that affects more
people yeah
um and two I also think that
I don't know like there's so many shows
about politics yeah I give every angle
and there's so many people that know so
much more than me I'm just like I'll let
them do you live what you say which is
it because you know you're in the thick
of it right now like I'm doing this show
I I kind of fuse politics I don't know
how much you know about my show but I
fuse politics and dating and
relationships together but I'm married
and I'm older and I have a child it's a
different perspective you're in the
thick of like I don't know if you are
dating or if you're out there in the
scene seeing these things female
promiscuity like I don't know if you're
out in the club being like Oh my God
what's going on here I don't I don't
drink so I'm like okay I'm good on that
but do you live like do you live what
you say in other words are you somebody
who you know how do you live your life
when it comes to dating a relationships
how do I yeah I love how I say you know
you do I mean I would say I've
definitely there are things in the
how do I put it like I think there's
been times in my life where maybe I
prioritized like volleyball that was
like the love of my life like you know
over relationships and I probably
shouldn't have done that in hindsight
um but you know now that I've really
like thought more about it I'm like I
feel like relationships should be at the
Forefront you know but you are so you're
traditional you know you believe no I
can't be true I feel like traditional if
you're not a virgin you're a traditional
woman like traditional women get married
at 22. I wish to God I was not anymore
though I feel like now that's changed
where like you I guess the definition of
traditional has changed a bit too in the
sense that like for me now when I look
at women modern women for me traditional
means someone who's not sleeping around
with everyone who's selective who
respects their body not necessarily a
virgin but someone who equates sex with
emotion and has is a relationship person
and is is thinking about marriage and
family and not necessarily climbing that
CEO ladder as a priority that's what
traditional sounds like see to me I
think of like a 22 year old virgin do
you think that how many of those you
think exactly I think they're rare I
mean that's why I think like it's so
funny that modern women want traditional
like we want traditional treatment but
we're not we're not traditional that's
just my opinion on it um
so I I'm trying to be more traditional
that's why I started the second Channel
have you seen wife school no I haven't
okay so let's go to live school it's
live school so you know I'm not gonna
say I'm perfect right I'm not gonna come
here and say I do everything right I'm
the epitome of a traditional woman I'm
not I got I got areas I need to improve
so
um what we did is we're bringing in
wives to teach modern women how to be
more traditional and I'm going to do
season one and basically every episode
we try to do things like that are more
traditional so first episode I don't
know how to dress
um like at all and the the comments were
saying we didn't do I need to learn more
because they didn't like the outfits we
picked anyway but but I was an athlete
like the first half of my life like that
was all I cared about so
um what I did was I was like okay let's
bring in a guy and we're gonna get a
guy's perspective on like what they like
like women to dress in Ally who's
married right yeah so then episode two
we already filmed I learned how to make
a cake from scratch and I learned how um
to cook I think it was stir-fry I forgot
what it was but the cake was really hard
they took away my blender I'm like I
can't and I was I was so confused I'm
like Auntie why would you not use the
blender it's here it's here I wasn't
very it humbled me because I think I'm
strong until I start blending and I'm
like Ow like my arms are so you know as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible